we return to our breaking news overnight
famed nfl coach john gruden is out after
a new report found he repeatedly used
anti-gay in racially insensitive
language in emails gruden resigned from
the las vegas raiders last night it came
less than two hours after the new york
times revealed a series of gruden emails
with bigoted language in one of them
gruden used an anti-gay slur to describe
nfl commissioner roger goodell he also
is accused of using a racial stereotype
to describe the head of the nfl players
association dimari smith joining us now
is bill rhoden of the undefeated a
website that focuses on race sports and
culture good morning bill how are you
doing
hey nate good morning how are you
thank you for joining us now days ago
groot did apologize for the racist trope
and then he also admitted to um using
racially
insensitive messaging to roger goodell
but he stayed on the job though um why
do you think things changed
well you know it was one thing to uh i
think when it was just about demora
smith
uh if he had just been kept at that
maybe he could have gotten the pass but
after the times revealed not only uh was
it about race but he was homophobic he
was misogynistic uh he checked almost
every box for a bigot and a racist and i
think at that point i don't think that
mark davis really wanted to find him he
gave this guy a 10-year contract i don't
think he wanted to but uh he just had to
you can't have a guy like that
patrolling your sidelines particularly
at a time
when the nfl is talking about diversity
and black lives matter you can't have a
guy like this on your sideline even
though what he wrote uh was about 11
years ago so uh they had to they had to
make this move and frankly i was
uh i was not stunned by the fact that
gruden would be this kind of person uh i
was just a little surprised that the
raiders finally had to pull the trigger
so bill why were you not surprised that
gruden might be this kind of person
behind closed doors because i'm thinking
mike trico and tony dungy two of his
colleagues said on air in the immediate
aftermath that they had never seen
anything from him like this and if
people knew it raises the question of
why was he employed for so long
well of course i mean i mean he wouldn't
say those kind of things to dungeon to
rico
you know he wouldn't refer to
the size of the uh of their their lips
or their no you know they you know
people like who are bigots
they don't say that stuff to you you
know so i don't think that taric or
dundee would see that part of him but
clearly
uh and this was my concern going forward
you know uh gruden had a group of
enablers and you we've all been around
these kind of people tell the racist
jokes uh talk about women uh among their
cadre of friends in circles who enable
them so i'm just concerned with
i like when the nfl as they go through
these emails who did he write these to
and what was their reaction uh bruce
allen who was the president of the uh
of the of the washington football team
you know what was his response when he
talked about uh you know demoris's lips
did he joke did he say lol you know so
moving forward i like to round up all
the enablers because you know facing
nate a lot of these people
are executives uh and probably hold uh
high positions in different industries
they're the ones who determine who gets
hired who gets promoted um you know he
mentioned that he thought that um
uh
you know the cornerback who's out the
league now who continued to kneel uh he
said that he should be fired you know
don't think for a minute groot is the
only person who thinks like that you
know so
i just think that as we move forward on
the story i want to find out who are his
enablers who are these people who are
now kind of scurrying back into these
dark corners who are just smart enough
not to put their racist beliefs and
emails
yeah you're touched on it briefly which
leads me to my question what does the
nfl need to do and is change possible
you know the nfl and roger goodell in
particular spend a lot of time saying
there's no place for this kind of
behavior we won't tolerate it and this
is what what we're going to do
well you know gail we've talked about
this so much it's hard to uh change
people's hearts what's in their hearts
you know this was clearly uh in gruden's
heart and soul he was just stupid enough
or emboldened enough to put in an email
uh how do you root out this kind of
stuff you know in the past year we've
had people we thought were allies uh
saying things when they didn't think the
tapes were rolling uh that sort of
betrayed their real feelings so how do
you out this kind of stuff i i don't
know maybe you just want people just to
keep their bigotry to themselves
you know i
again that's like i said gruden just
sort of served himself on a platter
uh but i think it's the the thing to me
is just the enablers those people who
are who enable these types of people but
how do you root it out that's the
million-dollar question how do you
change people's hearts
bill thank you for joining us and thank
you for not holding back we appreciate
you